With our physical material now set up,
the last thing that we're gonna do
is put in the landscape visibility mask
so that we can have holes inside of our landscape
to allow any users to go underneath our landscape.
While we are not necessarily gonna be building
any elaborate cave systems or anything like that,
this is just a really good thing to know about
in case your project does require
some type of cave system.
And here is an example on the screen
of what I'm talking about.
Here we have just a normal area
and then we have the masked area.
And what is actually happening
is we're actually painting this out
and not only are we painting the visual data out,
but we're also painting the collision.
Now, this is actually fairly easy
to set up inside of our material.
All we have to do is change our material domain
from its defaults blend mode to masked.
And then inside of our opacity mask input,
we have a special node called landscape visibility mask.
Now, if you want to get a little bit more advanced
with your setup,
you can select each individual landscape tile.
And there is this landscape whole material,
which will allow you to specify a specific material
instead of having to have a landscape visibility mask
for your entire landscape.
For our project here,
what we're gonna do is I'm gonna hit control space
and I'm gonna open up our matte landscape.
And so first things first,
we're gonna come over here to our blend mode
and we're gonna change this to mask.
And then I'm gonna zoom in here
and over here we have our opacity mask.
So we're gonna look for our landscape
and we want our landscape visibility mask.
So right there.
And then we're just gonna plug this in like so.
Once that's done, let's make sure we apply this and save.
And while that saves,
the next thing that we need to do is in order to use this,
we have to come over to the sculpt section
of our landscape tools, click on visibility,
and then we can paint in our visibility
or hide our visibility
just like we're sculpting in landscape.
So let's take a look at that now.
All right, I'm gonna go ahead and close this down
and then I'm gonna come up here to our selection,
to our landscape, I'm gonna come over to sculpt
and then we're gonna look for our visibility,
which is right here.
And then make sure my brush isn't too large.
And then I'm just gonna hold down the left mouse button
and you can see that I'm starting to paint in there.
And then if I hold down shift,
you can see that I've added that right back.
And let's just go ahead
and show you that we can actually go through this.
We're just gonna play from right here.
So check this out, just drop right off there.
So it does create a hole that you can go inside of.
And again, this is useful for anything, a cave system.
If you want to have maybe a house
that is partially set inside of the landscape,
or you've got maybe a very large building
and you have sub floors
that need to go underneath the terrain
and you don't necessarily want to get rid
of a square component or push it all the way down.
This is a great way to get rid of those landscape areas,
both visually and remove the collision.